so
okay welcome to the live stream for
everyone we are doing a bit of a
brainstorming discussion
about welcome language design for
stateful computation
and um just sort of a reminder of what
the issue is
right now
uh when we uh this is uh let me just
save this uh it's an appropriate place
here
um
uh see i'm gonna i'm gonna start a whole
uh folder about stateful computation
because i think this is going to there's
a folder in sw notes
what's it called
stateful computation huh
so predictable
thank you
okay great
okay all right
so i just want to you know
the
let's just enumerate
modes of computation today
right we have
the standard repel
in
goes down
okay
we have
right now
we have um
we have progress monitoring
which is which has a slight variation
from that
and we have we have dialogues which
we're not using much of
um
uh we have
then we have dynamic right i was just
gonna say dynamic if i could find the
unmute button
um
there's stuff like uh scheduled tasks oh
yeah right right those are sort of
outside of this um
synchronous evaluations
what's that i think i think that the
point is that there are synchronous
evaluations yeah yeah right i mean
there's a whole external while dynamic
is for the front end
somehow
yes right
but then
okay so you know what i have in mind
here
okay that then something that is coming
soon
is
uh evaluation graphs
of for info well
slash infinite evaluations
right but that's the whole big study
of there's an evaluation that never
terminates but yet you can see things
happening with it
wait is this is this the multi stuff
that's ultimately a multi year but multi
is even beyond that because there's x
equals x plus one
which right now just hits a limit and
stops
but we could imagine
a harness i mean so so that's so one
case is sort of infinite computation
uh infinite computation so we could
imagine something
say harness of x equals x plus one not a
very good name but you know what i'm
saying comma and then some specification
of what you what it does
because that's the thing where
you know you might just say i want to
block it at this horizon or something at
this moment
or i want to i don't know what you want
there you know you you could want a um
you know for example you could imagine
something that's called you know
evaluation list
that gives um you know
uh
uh moments
you know in the evaluation so to speak
we call that trace i mean yeah what's
the point the point is with an infinite
one you can't really do the whole trace
but right yeah okay basically does this
right right exactly but so the question
is with an infinite one you know how
should we think about that
computationally okay but that's
that's different that's not subject to
go go ahead okay i was about to ask do
you want to open the this infinite uh
no problem right no we don't want to
deal with the internet case what we're
now dealing with go ahead one case that
is not listed above and is probably
close to what we are discussing today is
streams like uh
these we do have like some stateful uh
objects in the language already
yeah okay which is in and out but with a
side effect
so you reading that you stream in output
out and you advance the stream on the
side without actually asking for it
yes
i mean what i have in mind you might
also include data structures too which
have kind of similar behavior
yes
okay so look one thing is memoizing
right we've obviously had this you know
the standard memorization
you know idiom
and so on forever
okay so we've got
uh we've got memorizing we've got a lot
of internal caching we've got explicit
memoizing
we've got implicit caching of which we
have quite a bit
what
and that's something we could consider
more of okay so
an example of that we've got um explicit
caching
of which um
the most notable example is local cash
where does ones fit in this picture
that's more like explicit caching
or maybe like explicit memoizing
yes what's the difference in memorizing
and caching
i guess it's a place where it's stored
i've never used local cache but
well local cache is just a down value in
in the end so it stores in memory is is
localization memory or on disk it's a
memory
okay
i thought you could have like local
caches in a cloud object and things
right yeah local cache is
moving something from the cloud to your
local file system
i see basically right so so so local
cache is file backed
and and then file back
okay
yeah it looks like it turns it into a
local object
i see explicit explicit
persistent caching
i see only if it's
now the default location is
session based so you would have to act
actually specify
no sorry local cache is persistent once
is not by default
okay so defaultly
persists across sessions
and once defaultly doesn't persist
defaultly doesn't persist across
sessions
okay so
the next big story is approximate
memorizing
which i claim is part of a machine
learning workflow
um if you tell me what it is like okay
so what what i mean is
i've got a function f
and it's very expensive to compute i
compute f of 7.8 it grinds for a long
time it finally gives me an answer okay
then i ask for and i compute several
other f's
then i ask for f 7.81
and the question is
can i get that back fast albeit
approximately
that seems like a kind of arbitrarily
hard problem yes well it is but if it's
continued right if it's continuous and
you have enough data i mean right
i i know but but that the whole point
here is what what i'm trying to do
is we've talked about reinforcement
learning and things like this
okay
and we've struggled with what the
workflow is what the computational
workflow what the mode of computation
for reinforcement learning is and i'm
claiming that one important workflow is
you're probing the world to try and find
out what's true about it
for the sake of being able to answer the
question what will this do
without having to actually do it
well this is the kind of active
prediction or active um classification
yes we we need to cycle back to those
functions because they are not so well
developed but that this is precisely the
idea you want to
to basically set up a model um with a
minimal amount of expensive calls
as possible right but my question is is
there a consumerization of that idea
that would be useful
well one thing
is for example
uh
you are exploring you are doing
optimization yeah you are exploring
hyperparameter cases
so you could use active prediction with
the
with the loss
and say try with these parameters and
try to infer what happens you know uh
if you if you change uh if you change
the l1 uh regularization in steps
you you don't want to do too many of
those of course okay let's let's start
off with explicit memorizing here okay
given okay so
testing for pure code
for
if we could test for pure code
we could make a decision to basically
always memoize certain kinds of things
could we not
one thing that that
i'm i'm
wondering a lot about is
where do we attach these these i i don't
know that's that's a big issue that's a
big issue which is why i've started off
by talking about these modes of
computation
because we don't have a good way to
attach
just like
right we just have ex you know our usual
mode of computation is you have an
expression you hit it a bunch of times
you get to a fixed point you return the
result
right so yes it requires a new model for
that
that's why i'm bringing it up in this
context that what i'm saying yeah
just like
you know for an infinite computation we
have no idea where to attach results to
where to
attach i mean
you know from the point of view of
memoizing
okay so so if we say
we could could silently memorize
in the background
but you never need to know where it is
but it's just an optimization
see what i'm saying
yeah there is a bit of a memory versus
time travel absolutely absolutely
i mean there's complicated trade-offs
but but one can imagine something if we
could test
that this is pure code you define a
function f g whatever it is
there's actually no reason we can't just
store the results of those things
if we knew
just like you know just like
right now we know when something has
been evaluated we know it's been
evaluated and we say we can just use the
previous value
we don't have to um go and reevaluate it
i mean that's a you know
uh
ju
it's analogous to testing does is
analogous to testing whether revaluation
is necessary
right it's like like just store
i mean
you know actually i mean internally deep
in the guts of of the system and the
evaluator we are doing things a bit like
this we're just not doing it
for i mean in other words what is the
reason why we don't just defaultly
memorize fibonacci for example
other than the memory trade-off which i
understand but we haven't thought about
this in 30 years so the memory changes
it's really hard to know if there are
side effects and and often you know the
minute you use module for example
technically there are side effects even
if it doesn't matter
okay
but we can define this i mean
you know
doesn't the compiler of their side
effects
um
well it's
let me see almost certainly you could
tell
if there are more side effects there's
certainly um
[Music]
uh so so they're two things i mean the
first thing is that the compiler already
only has like limited support for
global variables or you know closures
that modify variables you pass into them
and so on although both of those things
are probably going to change um but so
in that sense you almost it's you know
you're more limited in the side effects
you can have of course if you did
something like you wrote to a file
then
that would obviously have side effects i
know there's also a distinction that i
don't it's in a bunch of compiler code
where it's functions are tagged as
whether they're whether they're sandbox
only and or
basically whether they're sandbox safe
but i'm not sure if that's really that
list has been maintained
okay
but
i think it should be possible to do a
side effect test
um and if we found that something had no
side effects
how useful would it be to memorize it
i mean
you know let's assume that we
put aside 10 gigabytes to memorize
things
we could probably memoize a lot
and we have a you know an lru strategy
you know we have some standard cash
you know
you know sort of cash cashing strategy
for that
what do people think about this
maybe we have the wrong people roman do
you have an opinion about this
well i mean for pure code i mean
certainly
worthwhile to think about it and
i assume you could
as you said just make sure that if you
actually do reuse something then it
would would have
a longer lifetime but i'm not sure how
how much code there is actually is that
would benefit from this however because
not a lot of code is actually pure in
the sense of not having side effects
and not only is is most code
not conceptually pure but even code that
is conceptually pure is not technically
pure i understand but we could we could
make the decision that certain kinds of
things
would be
you know that it doesn't define certain
kinds of side effects well i don't know
we'd have to look at the go ahead well
so what about what about i mean i think
another thing that's that's in the same
vein would be making a version of once
where you can limit
its
sort of pool like that that it will fill
up
right because i mean that this is the
thing that's like i don't i don't use
once a whole lot products i don't use
memorization a whole lot but but one of
the reasons that i'm i'm always wary of
using something like once is that it's
like well
am i going to accidentally be cashing
25 gigabytes of stuff
um yeah that's a good point
that's a good point
i mean being able to have an option to
once
or even a default thing
that is the once cash so to speak the
size of the ones
yes but on the other hand
if you
decide to use once i mean the reason is
probably that
inside there is a really expensive
computation which
almost by definition is worth saving
yes but the question is what the
i i understand that but but
well sometimes like there have been
times when i've won so it's okay maybe
maybe once is already not designed for
this but there have been times when i've
had relatively cheap computations
where i might have memoized it but you
know but but i didn't but i could have
also used once
right where it's where it's something
like oh i'm going to call this
relatively cheap function a million
times
but of course it'd be faster if it
wasn't uh
how does that work i mean if i say f of
n blank colon equals
you know whatever it is the fibonacci or
something
and then i just want to once if i if i
do the following thing if i say
um
i'm going to regret this because i'm
gonna this will confuse this session
forever that's all right i can kill this
session
while you're typing that i just want to
offer the comment that maybe it's just
me but i don't really use ones for
memoization i really use it for like
initialization yeah same here so
same here
right but so okay so i do this
i do this and then i do my thing now if
i wrote wrap to once around here would
it do the right thing would it do what i
expect would it memorize
anybody
i would guess yeah but
you upset them
is 20 already big enough that it could
be minimized it would take forever
no i don't think so but 200 is
i think that memorized
how would i tell what the once cache
hasn't
okay there's for an example in that docs
page there
surely you should use echo here
that should have changed
maybe possibly well i mean it really
doesn't matter whether he's using echo
or not right since the the thing that's
returned is the random reel suppose he
could just do an echo of random right
yeah that value is discarded
okay sorry what were you going to say
though
where was the thing that shows the once
cache
i would have to search for it as well
because i don't you actually remember
well i mean a simple test is to do a fib
two that doesn't have a once in it and
see how you know if that one takes
forever okay fine
and if you try this one again it should
be faster
it was very fast anyway but let's see
i think favorite 200 will just never
finish
yeah that's what i can do so i did the
right thing
i've never used that term
i've never used it i mean it's a
reasonable thing to do
but
with this point about
you know
one can imagine a rapper here that just
says do reasonable memorization
with a reasonable strategy
like lru for example
basically it's just a programmer saying
assume this is pure yeah
would it be an attribute of the
of the of the function
no i think so i think what should i
think i think could be almost a function
that says memoize
you could just have a thing called
memoize that is
uh well maybe that's too extreme but
that has a bunch of stuff
that has equipment so to speak for
giving strategies and um
um
see what i'm saying i mean that
basically
then it silently
memorizes it up to some limit where it
is
you know making sensible use of it's
memoizing assuming assuming it makes
sense to memorize
does that make sense so i mean look this
is a case that seems reasonable to me
you know
i would use this i think quite a bit i
mean i think if i have code
where i expect that it is
i mean i would throw this in all the
time if i think it's pure code
um
i think by the way
does it matter that i'm not familiar
with this acronym lru i think that you
oh least recently used i think that
that's
um that's just one i don't remember
roman christopher somebody i don't know
what are some typical cash replacement
strategies
i'm not sure but i think there's by the
way a data structure for lru caches
oh
i'm not sure it's documented though
well that seems rather relevant to this
oh yeah it is documented
least recently used cash
what do you know
okay
so maybe this is something we should try
and consumerize here
fix size cash where keys and values are
general expressions
well whatever i mean that seems useful
okay but but this is the things i've
been talking about here are all exact
caching
there's also this approximate caching
approximate memorization idea do people
think that idea is stupid
i mean i was attempting to
is the thing again
that
you know we have a big success with
classify of packaging machine learning
in a way that's actually useful
it seems like another case is this
active learning type thing or something
where
you're using machine learning to speed
up a computation
and where
you want something which incrementally
does it's not like predict where you say
here's all this stuff learn it now
then i'm going to you know make use of
it later it's like in the course of
doing this
you are sometimes going to actually do a
computation and sometimes you're just
going to infer it from stuff you've seen
before i mean it's you know it's typical
active learning practical you know it's
what humans do as well
you know oh i just remember that versus
so i have to work it out again
julia you understand what i'm saying yes
so i mean would that be useful to have
something where it's like if it was
close enough and again it's going to
require criteria which are non-trivial
you know if it's kind of close enough if
you're solving some let's say you're
solving some eigenvalue differential
equation e
something or other you know chemistry i
don't know what the heck it is problem
okay
and
it's like a tweak on a problem you've
already solved
well then you might have reasonable
confidence that you can just interpolate
you can get an answer really quickly as
opposed to oh my gosh i never looked at
that before i need to do an ab initio
calculation it's going to grind for five
minutes
how does this relate with the
level of uh
input that you want to cache
like if you are thinking about like one
cell at a time but what if i'm nesting
many functions do i
cache each output
um i don't know if i was clear like f of
g of of f
of h of something and maybe one like the
internal one takes a lot of time but
should i repeat
the
i don't know i hadn't thought of that
um
well i was thinking
i was thinking more that it's only the
top level that was all i was thinking
about
as opposed it's a reasonable suggestion
but i mean the scenario again i'm
repeating the scenario you know we've
got plenty of places where
you know like for example it will be
useful to us for some things where we do
computations to basically ship
a look okay a trivial example of
memorizing that we already do is prime
pi
okay prime pi
we know certain
you know
waypoints in prime pi
so we don't have to compute you know if
i say prime pi of 10 to the 10
for example
i mean
another version of this is sort of
waypoint
memorization
okay so for example if i say prime pi
of 10 to the 10 plus 30
okay it comes back pretty quickly
because it probably memorized 10 to the
10.
did you understand what i'm saying
i mean we we do this in a lot of places
we have internal caches
what you clear with clear system cache i
don't know if prime pi is using that but
internal caches or or you know just
table lookups for
important or small values et cetera
right
right so
that is i mean that is an opt-in thing
yeah and the advantage is that you know
what exactly at which point you want to
opt in
but an internal code but i'm i'm saying
i'm saying that you
you know
imagine you have something where for
example we say uh you know we have a
function that says
um
you know approximate or
um
i don't know let's say learn memoize bad
name
okay of f of x whatever it is
right and here we give a lot of
parameters
about um
you know
here are parameters that say how close
do you have to be how certain do you
have to be
et cetera et cetera et cetera before you
just say and then you do that and then
you say f of 0.8
you compute it now you do f 0.85 you get
a value now you do f of 0.81 and by the
way it never doesn't have to recompute
it
because your parameters are such that it
says just it's probably going to be okay
you know if 18.85 are only one percent
different and you i who knows what the
criteria are
do you get what i'm saying
yeah this is mostly impossible if you
have black box code though
no it's impossible julio this problem is
impossible
just like classify as impossible predict
is impossible
every machine learning function is
impossible this is no
no
this is this is a whole different level
i mean i could define a piecewise
function that returns a graph between
8.1 and 8.2 yeah guess what if i run
that and predict predictor is going to
fail
yeah sure it has the same level of
possibility or impossibility that
predict has
is it's not like active predict
basically it's active predict it's
basically a packaging of active predict
but is that actually useful because
active predict will almost certainly be
slower than running this function
well
and if the function i mean if the
function is is reasonably cheap
then then active predictor will probably
be slower and if it's really expensive
then i think that the the sort of
automatic caching will probably not be
enough to sort of get around the fact
it's really expensive
okay look look the scenario that i have
in mind
is
let's
consider i don't know computing
something in chemistry where you're
gradually increasing the you know you
gradually you you've got some whole
complicated thing you've got a a 30
parameter object
that has different you know atoms in
different places or whatever else it is
okay
and it's a 30 30 dimensional space
and you are
you know and it's pretty smooth the
values of the function are pretty smooth
in that 30 dimensional space
yes for every separate value you can go
in and compute i mean we've i've got
millions of examples of this although i
can't think of ones
immediately that that um but there are
plenty of examples where where you know
it's a high dimensional space
you know it's pretty smooth or you can
deduce that it's pretty smooth now of
course it might not be smooth it might
be that it's smooth except for this one
little tiny hole in it you know the
black hole in the otherwise smooth space
but you know predictor is going to fail
at that as well
making sense
this is not as dumb as an idea as you
guys are making it seem like this is a
well well let me just i mean
i i i don't know exactly what examples
you have in mind but i would point out
that in chemistry right that that
singular point is singular space is not
going to be a point it's going to be a
hypersurface because it's called a phase
transition
well
for example that might be one thing yes
i mean the whole point is predict is
going to fail at all those things
right so if predict is useful which it
is
it can be used for these purposes too
the only question is the packaging of
predict because predict is a learn once
you know it's go to school early in your
life and never learn again type thing
well there's one one big issue here
though like
predict as
like is a numerical univariate functions
that it approximates
if you are talking about something that
can work for every possible output in
the language
even if it is not if it is well behaved
no i i
let's just box this problem in for a
minute okay
the
you know even if it is
multiple numerical parameters in which
predict also deals with to one numerical
parameter out
if we consider that case right now
obviously you've got a decoder you know
net decoders and so on which potentially
can lead to more complicated
expression structures as output
but i don't think that was what not what
i had in mind i was more interested in
things where the output is fairly
straightforward
okay but this is this is a very
narrow applicability window for
something this journal i don't know
whether it's that okay look
i don't know how we package this okay
the concept would be to have something
that is ultimately quite general
although it might start
you know i mean this is okay
this is kind of a
a continuous analog of programming by
example
no okay but take something like
adjacency metrics
so the adjacency graph metrics in graph
out
it's
it's hopefully huge hopeless it's
hopeless hopeless and isn't even useful
for this
the case where this is interesting is
where there is an internal computation
that is solving some differential
equation or this side of the other thing
or or doing something where there is
some expectation of continuity that's
the same
let me remind you machine learning is
impossible
right
and and
it's only going to work if there is some
simplicity in the world so to speak i
mean the question is
you know i mean does it even is this not
just like a taylor series or
interpolation or something it might be
you might use interpolation yes it might
use
you know it might use fancy machine
learning it might use interpolation it
might use some straightforward machine
learning the point is more packaging
than it is methodology inside i'm not
worried about being able to do this
internally i mean julia was right that
to return an arbitrary expression is
much harder but to do this in the same
way that active predict does it
for example
the inter the inert should be fine
unless that function is horribly broken
which it might be
and you you would you would use it like
you use the once in the definition of
fibonacci recursion exactly
exactly we put it in there
learn memoize with put in there with f
of x
in the definition right
um but learn memoize would have certain
parameters which tell it
oh you know use it in this way i mean
just like
you know predict no doubt has certain
parameters although it has a lot fewer
than you might think
so i mean the concept here is
that this is something where
if
and by the way okay so let me give an
example of where this is complicated and
where once
okay here's the issue let's say that we
have one of these things and it's for
some chemistry thing
whatever it is and
somebody
evaluated it's sort of key
uh memorization points
okay and there's one megabyte of data
associated with those memorization
points
so what we need is a workflow and maybe
it's just the cloud
where that memo data can be transported
around
do you see what i'm saying because
usually
when you define a function with learn
memoize there
there is no
we can have an invisible cache and we
don't have a problem with that
but our standard evaluation workflow
does not allow for
i think somebody had raised this earlier
where do you store the stuff
right and once stores it in the ether of
the local session
see what i'm saying
so the question is where does learn
memoize store its megabytes of data that
is its memorization is its prediction
function
you understand the question
well that's going to be this
probably a similar thing as what we have
for persistent value
yeah i would think so we can use that
framework for that
but so yeah right fair enough so then it
can store it in the cloud it can store
it locally there's a question where the
defaults are
um etc
right but i mean
okay
my goal here the reason that we brought
this up is because i was trying to
consumerize
some of the pieces of machine learning
that are currently not consumerized and
never used by people
like active predict
okay so julio yep respond to that i mean
you know to me this looks sensible right
particularly if we think about using the
the persistent objects mechanism to
store the back end caches
this looks quite sensible to me
i mean it's like storing
a
very local
neural net repository entry
that's just associated with this one
function you push it into the public
cloud
and it sits there
waiting for the cache to be used
you're very hesitant what are you
hesitant about
uh
well it sounds
very
unexplored so before like i would like
to spend the
sometimes exploring this and banging my
head against the problem uh okay well
but you understand
no no i i see you see your objective and
i see how this could be useful if
implemented correctly and uh
it's true that active prediction as it
is is not very useful so if we make it
if you make the idea if not the function
useful that that's nice
right right i mean so let's review for a
second you know where people would use
this is just an expensive numerical
function
where they would just wrap this wrapper
around it
so that
i mean it is making use it is making
a reality out of the claim that we are
increasingly making that machine
learning is the future of interpolation
so to speak
that you know a lot of numerical
analysis can be done better with machine
learning type methods than it can be by
you know by the traditional methods
and this is basically consumerizing that
idea
this is a good idea i'm sorry i think
this is a good idea i think we've got
two good ideas don't be sorry let's
we've got two good ideas one is
a a version of once
that has
reasonable memory you know cash memory
usage strategies
so that one can put it into with wild
abandon in one's code
without worrying about it and just like
well it'll make it faster if it
make
can
and
you know that will be strategy one
strategy two is to just do that behind
the scenes automatically but we think
that's too dangerous because of pureness
of code and things like this and maybe
maybe it's also pointless because most
of the time normalization is utterly
pointless
because most computations are
for a fresh so to speak
the the thing that scares me about this
is the
[Music]
subtleties of evaluation semantic like
for example you put once there in the
fibonacci definition
uh
if you have something like module m
equal m
and then you put once inside that
it doesn't have little and anymore it
has uh a model variable
yeah
like i mean i think that that's one of
the reasons why
i mean one of the things like if you had
a memoize function as well it might make
sense to make it a headdress
right because then then it would
struggle with attributes but it would at
least get um
you know it wouldn't get it wouldn't
struggle as much with like module
variables but so you you think on the on
the left hand side of that assignment or
when you
once you run it
so i think the idea would you'd say let
me see i think i think this makes sense
you'd say once a fib of n minus one once
a fib of n minus two etc
and then i think the idea is that
um
right that way the n minus one will just
evaluate and then you know that's not
part of the thing that's uh held instead
the only thing you know is you know the
head was fib
the only thing you have to cache was
that the head was fib and the input was
whatever it was
okay so that's a
they
but they still wouldn't solve the the
case i was making like if n is not
passed as uh
as value you don't see it at that point
well no i think you would right so if if
m if n was a a module variable the point
is the n minus one and the n minus two
would evaluate oh you want to let it
evaluate before okay okay okay okay so
you wouldn't get attributes right if fib
had attributes it would
this would mess it up
but um yeah
well that's a different idea i mean it's
a related idea
but honestly i think for memorization
that might be how it would have to work
to to get around the module problem
this is a big problem stephen
even when you're doing like opt-in cash
like in uh i mean the way we write
internal code is the way people could
write code uh and i think that a lot of
people wrote their own caches and the
thing is always
if you want to generate the cash key
what are the things that you want to
evaluate to to generate it actually
and
and might some of them might be relevant
some of them might be not relevant like
for example uh just something i work on
recently those impact plots
i'm caching the the sharp values
this is low computation if you want to
change the color of the points you don't
need to do that again you want the
output uh immediately yeah something
like word cloud i tried several times to
make a cache but there are like just too
many you know you could set
options of a cell and that would change
how stuff is is displaying on screen
so there's no way to to to cache the
shape of the words in a way that
that you have just basically every
front-end option and sell option and
input option so in in that case the
parameter space isn't that not cacheable
but in some cases you have clear
mental model of what are what are the
relevant well okay so the question is
right so
this is
uh
you know
cash ability
and you know what can
what can what you are doing
actually depend on
eg front end options etc etc
i mean so that is a question of
something that we are interested in for
other reasons like the compiler cares
about there's lots of things care about
this of of how pure is something
where are sources of impurity
or
you know external
list or
well i don't know what were you going to
provide a list or well i'm just yeah i
think there are lots of places where
where uh
you know impurities can enter
right but if we knew all of those places
if we can enumerate them we can detect i
mean then we can answer the question is
this cachable
well one of the issues is not only is it
that there are lots of places i mean
there's things like the file system
there's system options there's you know
whatever there's there's the symbol
table
but but there's also things where it
probably depends on
you know it
it might be hard to
like if you flag things at the
coarseness of of entire functions that
may be too coarse like there may be
things where well import is pretty much
always pure except for this one
right
right
one one interesting question is where do
we want to
stay like we have some code i think ita
you you you you fix some of tally's code
there like some uh
evaluation like might evaluate stuff
like uh
he's like oh like the yeah the uh
like the ha has down code but exactly
has possible evaluations queue exactly
exactly so the thing is uh
uh like value q for example yeah like
you you you want to um
if something is like do you want to do
you want that the true is always true
uh
and but so you if you say that it has
side effects are you fine if it doesn't
have it
but but you always catch when it has it
or the opposite you
yeah i'm sorry i'm tired but
you you see my point like
do you want to flag the code as safe
uh even if sometimes it's not safe or
the opposite you want to absolutely be
sure that uh i don't know it depends on
what you're trying to do exactly so for
this problem we might decide to air one
way or the other yeah like to to memoize
when maybe it's not necessary or to not
memorize when it would have been
necessary in in and that depends on
where do we want this thing to to to
lean
like is it an aggressive thing but if
you opt-in
yes i don't know we have to think about
it i mean we've got two different cases
here right we've got the case where
there's a bunch of semantics issues to
do with exact memorization and then
we've got the case where there's a bunch
of algorithm issues to do with
approximate memorization
those are the two things we need
the approximate
memorization
do like is it a super set of the
memorization or
or not like i think it's i think it's
related i think that the mechanisms
should be similar but i think that the
this whole question about the evaluation
semantics i don't know how important
that's going to be
i'm asking a different thing like if you
ask f of one
and uh when this approximate
memorization if i re-ask for f of one
should it use like the machine learning
thing or for like the stuff that it has
already compute it should be exact
i don't know
i think that's an option
i think it's an option it depends on
what you're doing
you know sometimes it would be better to
use the consistent machine learning
stuff i mean like like for example
here's a good question
if you ask for f of 2
and you're in a mode where f 2 is
deduced
automatically okay
and then for whatever reason
you are
and then you compute f yeah this is a
good example
you do f of two it's computed
automatically then you compute f of
three
which for whatever reason is explicitly
computed
that then changes the inferred value of
f of two
yep
right
i think that's life i don't think you
can avoid that if you're going to have a
learning function
that's what's going to happen
right even if even a thing that you
requested before might change its value
as a result of of new learnings so to
speak
yeah yeah but that's i mean if you're
opting in into machine learning that's
what you get yes
right so
as long as it's statistically sound like
it you know it shouldn't change
statistically even a value
that you requested before
might change
when another
explicit computation
gets done
right i need to run off to something
different here
um
but
i think both
of these things i really think are worth
exploring i think they're both pretty
decent ideas and especially
with your admission or statement that
there's a lot of internal code that uses
caching
let's figure out how to consumerize that
you know and that again becomes the
christopher semantics issues that's
important there for the machine learning
thing we need an algorithm we need to
know could our active you know could
active predict just do this out of the
box
right it's a squishy active predict like
a function that i don't know about yeah
yes
yes we don't we don't we don't talk
about it but yes
well we don't talk about i mean we spent
a lot of time working on it
and then i don't know the history of the
prediction but yeah it was at least one
or two years of work
yeah it was a lot of time spent on it
i think amir was the primary person who
worked on it
um you know a lot of time
spent on this and it's never used
because it is not packaged in a way that
anybody could you know can use it
and that's the goal here is to provide
you know
good packaging for this
see this is
this is exactly what we're looking at
here predictor function there you go
now you you add more values and you can
predict better
it's exact same thing right it has all
kinds of parameters et cetera et cetera
et cetera we need to understand how
those are more consumerized but that's
kind of the idea we should have i don't
know do we have any interesting example
here in this page because i mean this is
of course you'd never want to use active
position for doing plus two
but you
probably want to
i have no idea yeah i don't know i was
not pleased with this project basically
i mean i think i think maybe the raw
intel this project was never packaged in
a consumerizable way
okay
okay and that's that's the goal here is
that the chances are all of that
algorithmic work can just be used if we
can find reasonable packaging
all right i have to run but um
thanks